courage is with us in los angeles hi
courage welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave
anthony it's an honor to speak to you
guys god bless you you too how can we
help
yes i'm 20 years old i live with my
mother and my younger sisters i have a
job that pays 15
an hour but under the table um because
my mom
demanded me to do that to be paid that
way
um my family receives government aid
like fafsa and
food stamps um but i got off i got
offered a position at my current job
that would raise
my pay to 25 an hour on payroll on
payroll
um i strongly desire to take that
position but
my mother won't let me um i have credit
card debt that i need to pay off
um but then my my mother also takes
about 80 of my income so it's kind of
hard to do so
how old are you i was looking to get i'm
20.
what was your name again courage what
wow ouch yes sir say it again
courage yeah i thought so yeah yeah man
are you getting the message already
before you finish your question
i believe so it's um i just you know
i've been vocal to my mother about
um taking the position and also you know
been vocal about keeping my income and
also and all that stuff but
she's he's been kind of uh saying that
that was very selfish for me to
to even consider that or even think
about that it's selfish for your mom to
force this kind of demand on you
when you're trying to establish yourself
in life as a young man
and so let's let's not talk about the
word selfish because your mom is a
little bit more actually a lot more
selfish than you are right now
but let's let's address the problem at
hand are you living at home with your
mom right now
yes sir okay all right so right now with
you living in your mama's house
she feels as if she can tell you what to
do so the very next step is
you know are you in a position to leave
your mother's house
um i i strongly desire to and i'm
obviously trying to
find a place to move out but um like i
said before my mom takes
about eighty percent of my income so
anymore because you're moving out
yeah man i i don't have any friends that
have an apartment
that's right yeah uh
yeah i do i believe i do yeah would you
would any of them let you crash on the
couch for a month and you kept your
whole income for a month and then when
you got your own place
i do actually a couple that's what you
need to do yes
okay i don't want to be mean but you
need to hear this real loud and clear
you because it's hard to insult a guy's
mama okay
but your mama is out of control
yeah out of control yeah
yeah nobody takes their 20 takes 80 of
their 20 year old's
money and takes government assistance
this woman takes and takes and takes and
takes she doesn't give anything no
you need to love her from more of a
distance
yes yes sir i i believe so too
and uh you know at least i'm happy that
i the only the only reason why i let her
do that is because uh
i mean i i told her she can only do that
if he gives ten percent of its value
it doesn't matter that does not make it
right it doesn't make it right
it doesn't make right let me tell you
the number of times i took to 80 of my
kids money when they were 20.
zero i know that answer
yeah but here here's the thing courage
let me let me uh just give you the
process man
you need to have courage tell your mom
i'm leaving tell mom i love you
i'm grateful for you ask one of your
friends if you can crash on the couch
for a month
and then see if you have another friend
out there that you can roommate with so
that way you don't have to take on a
full 100 of the rent
okay and then from there you got to just
really be aggressive
on a budget living below your means like
you're broke how many hours a week are
you working at the 25
um well i currently work about 50
55 60 hours would you get that many
hours at 25
dollars yes okay yeah so you work all
the time like that
yes and very quickly you're gonna have a
pile of money when you're quit paying 80
of it out yeah
like in a month i mean just add up what
you'll make in a month at 60 hours at 25
and four times that for a month
yes sir okay and you're gonna have some
money dude yeah now again
i i'm with anthony i'm i'm i'm gonna
disrespect your mom but i don't want you
to
okay please i i think she's a turkey
but i think you need to be kind to her
and i think she's your mom
and i think you should always be
honoring of her and grateful
and uh she's not gonna like it when you
leave because you're one of her gravy
trains and the gravy train's moving yeah
this is going to be very um
there's going to be a lot of conflict
with this decision isn't there
yes sir it's not going to be pretty is
it yeah
no it's not that but she made a mistake
she named you courage
yeah so there you go all right
and listen let me give you one last
thing that goes with this okay
because of the the background that you
are coming out of and your 20 year old
young man trying to find your way
there was a book written years ago by a
man named tom stanley it's called the
millionaire next door where he studied
millionaires
then tom tom and i later became friends
and he later came back and wrote a book
called the millionaire mind
and he went and studied not millionaires
courage
but people with 10 million dollars or
more
deca millionaires they're called 10
million
and they were making an average of 750
000 a year
or more the men the men and women that
he studied
and as he studied them he found 35
statistical correlations
among all of them and then he ranked
them
from the most important and most most
reoccurring
of all the people that he studied down
to the least reoccurring
of the 35. you following me
so if i'm reading this book when i read
this book what i wanted to know is
what are the top five things that are
the characteristics
of people that make 750 000 a year
and people that have 10 million dollars
or more
is that interesting information yes yes
sir
you know what the number one character
quality was characteristic was
in integrity yes sir
and taking money under the table so that
you illegally get government assistance
is not integrity sir
yes courage i'm proud i i
i believe so i believe so yeah and it's
not that's why i'm picking on your mom
she can just quit trying to game you and
game the system
and roll up your sleeves and be somebody
yeah and that's what i want you to go do
right now
as fast as you can and as gently as you
can
but i know young man that you're going
to have some conflict from someone who
has a lot of emotional power over you
and this is going to require courage on
your part no
pun intended here brother but you can do
it you can do it and if you put it off
you're still going to have to do it it's
just going to be later
yeah and then you're going to be forced
to do it because you're going to be like
what in the world
eventually it's going to blow up on you
yep these things do not
end well they don't they don't end well
so go ahead and just
endure the pain now yeah and the
emotional pain of her
disapproval and if she wants to
disapprove of me
i can handle that yeah me too i'm pretty
good with that yeah
because that means i probably gave
excellent advice if someone like that
disapproves of me yeah
there you go and here's the thing too
dave she made me say you know i don't
want to talk to you anymore right now
yeah and that's okay she'll come back
around she'll come back around cause
she'll want money later